[Musique]
c'est la rumeur de la semaine la
ministre délégué en charge de la
citoyenneté marlène schiappa pourrait
potentiellement devenir animatrice télé
sur ces huit en tout cas tout le monde
en a parlé alors que le remaniement
ministériel est imminent le figaro
révèle qu'elle serait en pourparlers
pour animer sa propre émission sur la
chaîne je ne sais pas précisément qui
sont les noms des personnes qui sont
derrière tel qui est intervenu plusieurs
fois en tant qu invité dans l'émission
de cyril hanouna pourrait même se
retrouver autour de la table en tant que
chroniqueuse comme le révèle le journal
des informations que marlène schiappa
réfute contrairement à ce qu'écrit la
presse sans même avoir pris le soin de
me consulter sur la base de fantasmes je
n'ai aucune émission de télé prévues sur
ces vite je suis encore ministre et à ma
mission jusqu'à la dernière minute mais
ba ba n'a pas dit son dernier mot
j'attends ça avec impatience
alors justement je suis con mais tout ça
c'est des petits messages soir c'était
vrai effectivement pas forcément parce
qu'ils se disent havre est ce que c'est
vrai ce que c'est faux qu'est ce que
c'est que ces histoires alors le figaro
qu'est ce qu'ils lisent marne et ya pas
bientôt sur ces huit voix ce qui est
sorti dans la presse marine va pas
aurait fait plusieurs propositions
d'émissions notamment à moi même là moi
mais si son projet d'émission échoué
elle pourrait sur droit kazeon
chroniqueuse chez nous dans touche pas à
mon poste voilà ce qu'ils lisent marlène
schiappa vient de démentir il s'agit de
fantasmes et qu'elle n'a aucune émission
de télé de prévu
et je vais vous dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité bien entendu cette
vérité vous l'attendez vous vous dites
c'est est-ce que marlène schiappa va
prendre une de nos places autour de
cette date
est-ce que marlène schiappa
va en chasser une ou un pour être à sa
place car vous le savez une à 9
chroniqueurs malheureusement la table
n'est pas extensible ah ouais bon zizi
oui la table
donc forcément
c'est un nouveau chroniqueur récurrent
je vais devoir faire des choix
mes choix
sachez qu'ils sont déjà faits pour
l'année prochaine c'est vrai oui mme
habiba sur wii on n'est pas au courant
c'est normal ou ses hippo qu'on
n'est pas près d'être bien entendu
parcourir
marlène schiappa aurait fait plusieurs
propositions d'émissions notamment
à ma personne
si son projet d'émission échoue elle
pourrait sur le hockey / occasion
chroniqueuse de chez nous dans touche
pas à mon poste
quelle est la vérité sur ce dossier qui
dit vrai qui dit faux
le gouvernement at-il tremblay
et législatives
montel subir
se faire bousculer
qui dit vrai qui dit faux
est ce qu'un ancien membre du
gouvernement
va rejoindre
ses 8
est ce que cette personne
sera dans les animaux de la 8
6 à 7 est ce que cette personne
sera dans une émission en direct tous
les soirs où est ce que cette personne
aura son émission
mais aujourd'hui à 19h51 en direct
je suis en mesure de vous donner les
réponses aux questions que les français
se posent
marlène schiappa
marlène schiappa connaissez mon histoire
avec elle c'est la première qui m'a fait
confiance l'année dernière vont venir
parmi nous absolument faire une émission
à mes côtés je vais tout vous raconter
je me rappelle laisser cette musique
j'aime beaucoup
marlène au départ toutefois je vais vous
raconter toute l'histoire de marc laisné
mon mari ne m'avait convoqué dans son
bureau à l'époque
pour
des guillemets dérapages et ça avait
commencé comme ça
qui est arrivé en vélo
déjà on avait regardé de sa fenêtre
ministre grâce à la dîme quels beaux
petits mollets
et la
marlène et moi on s'est parlé on s'est
dit les choses à bâtons rompus
et puis on s'est rendu ces revues ont
réalisé cette émission première émission
btp spéciale
avec marine chapelle je me rappelle dans
son bureau elle m'avait dit faut faire
cette émission et j'avais dit à marie
n'échappe à marle aisne
est ce que tu as envie de tout le monde
en parle de cette émission et moi
l'important c'est que je fasse
l'émission je dis moi l'important c'est
de faire chier les gens
juridique marlène tu ne seras pas
invités de cette émission
tu seras coanimatrice de l'émission
ça fait le buzz que ça fait l'émission
avait cartonné et depuis on est resté
très pote avec marlène schiappa
gelé vu pareille ne va pas peu de temps
avant
les élections
lui un mois avant et bien sûr on a parlé
d'avenir
je lui ai dit
ma volonté
de vouloir lui faire faire la télévision
et de la radio je pense qu'elle a un
très gros talent je pense qu'elle est
fait pour que ça ne m'a répondu bien
entendu je ne peux pas positionnés pour
l'instant puisque je suis encore au
gouvernement je ne sais pas ce qui va se
passer ensuite peut-être que je vais
être encore ministre peut-être que je
vais faire ailleurs d'autres fonctions
au sein du gouvernement
mais on sort pas mais
jamais nous ne sommes entrés dans de
tels détails après elle m'a dit voilà ce
qu'elle aimait bien à la télé maggie
quoi laquelle ils adorent et les
émissions voilà de témoignages voilà
deux des dead pour des délais ou les
émissions qui aide les gens et c'est
donc on n'est jamais rentré dans ce
détail mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
marlène schiappa qui veut être
chroniqueuse qui va être animatrice
c'est moi en tant que producteur qui
elle suit d'aller la voir pour lui dire
que je croyais en elle parce que je
pensais qu'elle avait un truc à faire à
la tête voilà donc c'est pour l'instant
parlait n'avait pas du tout intéressé
mais elle sait que moi elle marque terex
en tout cas il ya une phrase qui m'a
interpellé dans l'article c'est si elle
échoue elle se retrouva chroniqueuse
dans tpm p c'est à dire qu'on a tous
échoué
c'est mal formulé ces malfrats non mais
voilà l'homme après voilà mais c'est
vrai que pour l'instant c'est une très
bonne idée au docteur ben car
effectivement elle serait excellence
dans
l'excellence sur les pavillons serait-ce
l'excellent voilà après je sais pas ce
qu'elle va faire j'sais pas si elle est
si elle a envie de faire d'autres
projets mais en tout cas c'est vrai que
voilà marlène ça a été la première à me
faire confiance c'est devenu un jeu le
lien voilà c'est devenu une amitié voilà
je pense qu'elle a acquise à faire je
connais voilà je je connais tout ce
qu'elle fait maintenant je sais comment
elle fonctionne et c'est vrai que voilà
je trouve qu'elle a un avis sur tout
donc ça me ferait rien vous connais vous
planifiez beaucoup à l'avance donc c'est
que vous avez en tête une idée
d'émission ou de concepts pour elle
est-ce que vous pourrez mesurer sur un
truc est-ce que vous pouvez nous révéler
cette idée non malheureusement je ne
peux pas un album as well as que ça
n'est pas pour s'est vite mais ça n'est
pas pour ses vitres à la produire
ailleurs oui exactement à la télé ou à
la radio
les do we les deux mais pour l'instant
voilà marlène schiappa pour l'instant
n'est pas intéressé voilà tueur europe 1
par exemple
non papa pas forcément non non non c'est
plein de radio qui pourraient être
intéressés par ailleurs on a vu sur rmc
donc voilà donc voilà pour l'instant je
vous lis ces dons c'est dans mon esprit
c'est juste moi qui ai sorti cette
affaire mais c'est vrai que je trouve
qu'elle serait elle serait pas mal que
vous en pensez elle est super c'est la
reine des punchline alors là elle a une
personnalité hors du commun pour moi
c'est pour moi elle a marqué le
quinquennat le premier quinquennat de
macron cl et gabriela talent aussi les
deux je trouve on était vraiment les
personnages forts qu'on en voyait
souvent d'ailleurs ou au casse pipe sur
des sujets très difficile sur les
chaînes d'info enfin elle est pour moi
elle est assez extraordinaire une
personnalité hors du commun oui dans
l'antre aide dans l'empathie justement
aller vers les gens essayer de trouver
des solutions de vie quotidienne parce
que j'ai trouvé indépendamment de toute
considération politique elle était très
dans la vie quotidienne des gens donc là
dessus je pense qu'elle pourrait être
super géraldine doigts serrés que tu
l'as tu la critique est arrivé de
l'atlantique une rémission mais un match
énorme que ce serait une recrue
extraordinaire qu'elle quelles que
soient les missions si c'est une mission
sociétal si c'est de l'info times enfin
je pense qu'elle peut tout faire elle a
beaucoup un vrai regard sur le monde sur
la société jamal a dit je suis d'accord
avec elle mais voilà fait absolument
brillante et même si elle voulait je
pense que pour tpm vais peut-être que
c'est peut-être pas assez bien pour elle
ou assez ambitieux pour elle mais je
pense qu autour de la table elle serait
fantastique ce serait une recrue en or